j'étais moi trois mètres de jérôme
rodriguez quand il a perdu son oeil
rappelle-moi la dalle jérôme c'était le
lundi 26 janvier 2019 j'étais à trois
mètres du jour antiguaise je couvrais en
tant que journaliste cette manifestation
depuis un long moment je suivais de loin
jérôme rodriguez parce que je voulais
interviewer mais j'attendais un petit
peu d'être à l'arrivée des émois jusqu'à
- surnom des gaz ne faisait rien elle
posait des étiquettes sur les sur les
poteaux et à un moment il prend un tir
de l'allumer de l bd totalement
injustifiée dans le visage
donc l'idée ce n'est pas de dire toute
la police est responsable de ça mais il
ya effectivement un problème parfois est
passé où je dirais même de temps en
temps souvent dans les manifestations
parce que c'est ce que je préfère c'est
important non mais c'est pas ça si je
suis plein s'aggrave
c'est ça qu'on essaie de déterminer
alors ce alors vitrine moi j'ai 33 ans
de terrain voilà les manifestations
j'ai retrouvé récemment des images que
j'avais tourné il ya plus de 20 ans dans
des manifestations et notamment
lorsqu'on investit cdd cité avec des
policiers lorsqu'il y avait des émeutes
et les images que je faisais à l'époque
je ne peux plus les faire aujourd'hui
parce qu'à l'époque on était au contact
des policiers
je ne vais pas dire qu'on était intégrée
aux policiers mais enfin nous laisser
travailler lorsqu'ils discutaient il
faisait rendez compte à leur hiérarchie
on pouvait le faire aujourd'hui on fait
attention
préparant un coup de matraque sur les
caméras et ça nous arrive et ça nous
arrive malheureusement avec ça change et
moi j'étais c'est le contexte way les
manifestations c'est pas celle de joe
locaux ce que je voudrais dire aussi qui
est très important c'est qu'on est en
fuite
ils ont déterré beaucoup plus de pavés
coup on a lu on a eu une manifestation
qui s'est très mal passé nous 23
novembre dernier quand des réfugiés et
des migrants ont envahi la place de la
république
j'ai plusieurs confrères amis notamment
clés - la noémie buzine qui ont été
frappés notamment rémi buzine par un
policier à quatre reprises jeté au sol
acquis par un policier lesquelles le
service où j'allais venir par une bac
ninh bac 93 94 et la fièvre s 94
absolument
le problème c'est que ces unités qui
fonctionne très bien leur travail sur le
terrain ne sont pas formés et bbc
les dix fois on répète la même chose que
le maintien de l'ordre est fait par des
gens méchants sur areva t voilà je suis
in a été frappé au sol à plusieurs on a
des images à vous à vous montrer voilà
c'est dit m j'ai tourné mon regard des
séries
[Musique]
voilà ce qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'à ce
moment là
ce qui me met quasiment jamais arrivé en
trente trois ans terrassé qu'un policier
de la bac
j'imagine de l'abacus qui étaient en
civil lui tente de marcher ma caméra
j'ai une carte de presse je suis
clairement identifié un policier n'a pas
à m'arracher ma caméra je n'essaie pas
d'arracher le pistolet d'un policier qui
fait du maintien de l'ordre il fallait
sur la voie publique
vingt quatre policiers n'a pas tenté de
m'arracher ma caméra voilà donc
évidemment à ce moment-là nous
journalistes on se met à crier on dit
rémy on va appeler le ministère parce
qu'on essaye d'avoir une petite pression
psychologique sur les policiers ça se
détend rémy est très en colère ce qu'on
peut comprendre et quelques minutes plus
tard le mal qu relier le même policier
va lui faire la même de nouveau une
quatrième fois sur la place de la
république
c'est totalement inadmissible alors ce
qu'il faudrait c'est inadmissible et
c'est selon vous inédit en trente trois
ans de métier alors oui ou non on a on a
vu on a vu effectivement moi j'ai eu je
regardais tous les trucs comme ça il ya
trente ans pour vous assurer que ça ça
se faisait pas à moi ya trente ans mais
il ya trente ans on n'avait pas du tout
le même rapport en toujours dit j'adore
caméra et avec deux caméras exactement
ce qu'il faut comprendre la compagnie va
même jusqu'à un truc vraiment important
et de contextes souvent les diverses
affaires préférera gaza ont fait mine de
l'oublier ce qu'est ce qui s'est passé
avec un musée n'est totalement
intolérables et ce qu'elle vient nous le
rappeler en cas d'annoncé c'est un
insupportable
en revanche peut-être un tout petit peu
pour dézoomer il ya un truc quand même
totalement nouveau
lui et la police visiblement on n'y est
pas préparé c'est pour ça qu'ils
essaient tension c'est qu'il ya 25 ans
il y avait deux caméras sur le terrain
mais une petite caméra tf1 caméras de
france 2 il y avait une petite chaîne
d'info qui se baladait avec une caméra
qui pouvaient même pas fini mais en live
aujourd'hui il ya 50 cents personnes qui
peuvent filmer en live en direct la
police c'est une bonne chose de mon
point de vue parce que cela permet prix
journaliste freelance qui le choque moi
même temps on attendait les choses
jolies mais bon quoi icpe qui relance
les bavures donc il filme et se pense
que ça change des choses et ça crée une
tension supplémentaire et c'est ce qu'on
a vu dans ce cas là et le ministre nous
a dit tout à l'heure puis j'ai eu
l'occasion de lui rétorquer son analyse
le ministre a dit on est dans une
société de l'image être d'image mor fall
alors jamais trop digne sa fin le schéma
le schéma nous voulons le nouveau projet
de d'où l'angoissé quand même toujours
plus de caméras de sécurité dans les
rues ce sont des drones il a parlé d'
images de caméras de plus en plus
installés sur des policiers mais très
bien mais moi je réduis ont mis sous la
lame et monsieur minutes dans ces cas là
il faut laisser le contrechamp ça il
faut laisser les gens tournée c'est ça
la démocratie
je vais vous je vais vous répondre parce
que là vous avez fait le prisme de ceux
de ce journaliste qui s'est fait
peut-être agresser je m'en suis d'accord
c'est vrai qu'on avance ensemble et de
la consécration remets en cause c'est
évident que le débat dont l'assassinât
avait nommément
ça c'est le script les gars des bacs ou
commissaires qui fait le croque à moquer
voilà quand on regarde de façon très
générale ce qui s'est passé surtout vous
allez remarquer que les gendarmes
mobiles et les compagnies de
sécurisation d'intervention 64 qui était
sur le passé lui la place de la
république où il y avait coquerel ou elf
y récupérer évidemment l'événement
ces policiers l'a été même pas casqué et
ça s'est passé correctement mieux ça on
n'a par contre pas si correctement ça il
ya eu quelques incidents mais c'était
quand même rires xxie autorisé faut
quand même regarder l'ensemble aussi ça
justifie pas les jours et revenir sur un
point qui est vraiment fondamental ce
soit là et qui a attisé la colère de
tous les journalistes dont moi le
premier puisque j'ai fait une vidéo à la
demande de mon avis david dufresne
j'ai attaqué frontalement le ministre de
l'intérieur parce qu'il s'est passé
quelque chose que j'ai quasiment jamais
vu en trente trois ans il faut peut-être
expliquer aux téléspectateurs qu'il ya
une technique de maintien d'ordre qui
s'appelle la nasse on l'appelle comme ça
quand dz envie du langage malbar
l'engagement c'est le terme technique
policiers nous on appelle ça la nature
journée sur la place à quand des
manifestants quittent un itinéraire
autorisés ou faut une manifestation qui
n'est pas autorisée que pour éviter que
la paire que pour éviter que la
manifestation ne se dispersent les
policiers arrivent de tous les côtés à
un moment menace en cage les
manifestants qui sont là - des neiges
dans ma carrière j'en ai vécu des
dizaines et des dizaines et des dizaines
en tant que journaliste on a besoin de
faire de ce qu'on appelle des plans de
coups de contextualiser ces tortillas et
c'est à dire de sortir de la nasse
d'aller faire des imacs térieur
peut-être d'aller ailleurs et pour la
première fois
l'autre jour ce 23 novembre nous étions
à ses tableaux faciles non c'était entre
c'était entre la mairie de paris est la
place de l'art est de la république dans
une petite rue d'anjou millions c'était
juste à côté de beaubourg donc nous
étions assez et les les policiers ne
nous dise
attendez on veut bien vous sortiez mais
on demande l'autorisation à la salle de
commandement c'est à dire anarchie
direct que dans général le préfet de
police nationale manqué dans celle de
commandement et pour la première fois
les policiers nous dise dans les
journalistes vous restez où vous êtes
traité comme les autres
non je me lâche et je ne l'avais jamais
vécu il s'est passé
d'accusation franchement il ya une
dégradation il n'y a pas de violence
eric g et des caméras et journalistes la
presse dégradation nous faudrait qu'on
vient de dire comme le sont les laissait
alors je ne vous donne encore deux
éléments parfois la parole
encore 2 et les dons encore deux
éléments qui sont très importants un
moment mal le dispositif est levé sur
ordre de la delà de la salle de
commandement de la préfecture et le
groupe de journalistes alors il y avait
un vide où il y avait des journées se
disent indépendants
il y avait des journalistes eux rouge
avec france 5 qui était la fin il y
avait vraiment un melting-pot de
journalistes et on apprend qu'il ya
d'autres incidents à la place de la
république où nous aurons dos à la place
de république dans une rue on voit au
loin une nouvelle menace pour la
première fois - 33 ans de carrière avec
mes confrères ont cédé eh ben on
s'approche pas on s'approche pas parce
qu'on ne sait pas si on va finir au
regard de nos journalistes en france
avec des cartes de presse avec des
cartes d'agents ce avec des caméras
identifiable reconnaissable nous nous
disons ce moment-là nous n'y allons pas
parce que nous ne savons pas si nous
allons en gardant moins d'une
détérioration des tout derniers plus
rapide à un moment juste avant
l'agression de rémy buzine la
manifestation sauvage cours
il est à côté de moi enfin devant bois
sur ma droite ajourné ce qui je crois
est 35 etc avec sa caméra qui courent et
qui filme qui essaient de films et
bredouillements ce qui s'y passe et un
policier derrière de la bac qui passe à
sa hauteur pour aller rejoindre c'est
qu'on est devant mais à coups de
matraque aux journalistes disent que ça
n'a aucune justification
on